most times whenever i make theories i
don't care if i'm right or wrong i'm
just like
would it be cool if this happened would
it be interesting if that happened i
don't know if it will but it'd be kind
of cool if it did
this is not one of those this this is
not one of those times okay
so here's here's the thing i'm gonna
blow your mind i'm gonna absolutely blow
your mind okay so here's the thing
you guys remember the guy in episode
number one
who got disintegrated when he didn't
have his little pass and he was giving
crap to the minuteman
and then like he screamed in the most
hilarious way possible as he was being
pruned
i think he was a loki i think the tva
exists to track down
loki's to eliminate loki's i think the
whole idea because here's the biggest
issue that i have right like yes
b15 c20 they work for the tva
they are considered variants they had a
life before they were part of the tva
but here's the problem with that how do
we know their variants
sylvie said they are but it doesn't mean
she's right what this would mean and i
get this idea that like if a person's
late for work
it means they went off their established
timeline i mean that seems pretty
ridiculous to me
right like literally like oh my god i'm
running five minutes late for work and
then you're
snatched up and then you're basically
taken to the tva like and then you're
essentially pruned right or you're
turned into a tva agent i don't think
that's what happens at all
i think that's a bunch of crap i think
that's just stuff being made up
to make it look like the tva serves this
grandiose purpose
of maintaining this multiverse i don't
think they do
one we know the multiverse exists we
know that from doctor strange one that
the ancient one was talking to stephen
strange and saying you know there's an
infinite number of universes out there
some of which are life-giving and some
of which are malevolent and filled with
evil
we know the multiverse exists what i
think is actually going on here
is i think the tva is trying to control
and contain the multiverse and the
multiverse is trying to break free
here's why i say that
there is a moment let's let's take some
of the stuff from loki right let's say
that like some of the things that have
been said in that show we can take
literally at face value even if the
people saying it don't truly understand
what they mean
or don't really understand the depths of
what they're saying that like we can
take it at face value right
let's take sylvie for example silvie was
a little girl who did something right it
was a nexus event and they basically
said okay like we're gonna snatch her up
we're gonna bring her into the tva she
escaped and she was on the run the
entire time but she tells loki
she tried to go back to her reality and
her entire reality had been wiped away
she couldn't go home right she literally
said my whole reality was destroyed
and so because of that she started
hopping and skipping through this point
throughout the time stream
and that she was creating nexus events
literally giving them a breadcrumb trail
to follow
and that's how they kept tracking her
down they kept locating her the other
thing about this
is that loki says we don't die we always
survive
in the beginning i would have said okay
so like it just happens to be that loki
did a thing and loki's being tracked
down by the tva and
that and that was basically it but then
you get to the end of episode number
four
and loki is quote-unquote pruned and
then wakes up in some
you know post-apocalyptic landscape with
other versions of loki
so here's what i think is going on here
here's what i think is actually
happening here the multiverse exists the
multiverse is
is there right it's a thing that exists
but it's being contained and controlled
by whoever it is that's running the show
now because we know it's not the time
keepers i still say it's miss minutes
but basically they're trying to keep it
contained and controlled
the multiverse is trying to break free
it's trying to get out right it's trying
to to expand and become a chaotic place
sylvie said that when she was talking to
loki she said the universe or the
multiverse is chaotic it's always trying
to break free that's why it manifests
chaos in the form of me becoming the
goddess of mischief here's a crazy thing
and jonathan hickman's avengers new
avengers you had like the the collapse
of the multiverse right the multiverse
just just
you know incursions worlds crashing into
each other black panther reforms the
illuminati and the illuminati trying to
figure out what's going on thanos and
his cabal are just going from alternate
world alternate world killing all life
on those earths and then blowing the
earth up but while all that's happening
the white lords of wild space or the
ivory kings beyond
whatever you want to call them you have
the black priests and the black priests
are these
wildly enigmatic beings you don't know
anything about them but you simply just
know that they're there
and that when the illuminati is watching
everything that's going on the black
priest will show up to a world they'll
obliterate all the superheroes or any
resistance on that world then they'll
destroy the world itself
then they'll move on to the next one
it's not until you get to eight months
later
time runs out that whole storyline where
doctor strange takes over the black
priests and you learn their origin
that if the multiverse was a sentient
being the black priests are antibodies
they're white blood cells they were
basically created by the multiverse for
the purpose of trying to stop the
incursions what if loki is the exact
same thing because
here's a crazy thing right we can even
take that further right because the
marvel cinematic universe has borrowed a
lot of stuff from jonathan hickman
that's where you got the
the call obsidian right so like the
ebony maw in corvus glaive proxima
midnight that was all from john and the
hickman stuff
another thing that happens in in
hickman's avengers new avengers is you
learn that the origin of the molecule
man owen reese
is the exact same across every single
universe there is no real deviation
there the circumstances of how he got
his powers
are the same right he inadvertently
created a cosmic cube and half that
energy went into himself now it may be
the location of where he got his powers
is different but the process is the
exact same we know from sylvie she was
adopted
that she is basically an alternate
reality version of loki there's no
reason to believe
she is not a daughter of a frost giant
of lofty most likely that she was
adopted by odin
probably frigate as well raised in
asgard and then snatched up and taken
away what i think's happening here is i
think the multiverse is trying to break
itself away
from the control of the tva and that
like like little
little leaks in a wall the tva is trying
to patch up all these little leaks with
like bubble gum
by basically rounding up loki's because
i think the multiverse is
creating loki's for the purpose of
creating chaos
creating mischief now here's the biggest
issue that i have with this right the
biggest issue i have is if that's true
then it makes sense why they snatched up
sylvie when she was so young
because maybe it's one of those things
where she was kind of kept hidden maybe
she was taken at a time that wasn't long
before that i mean she says she was
adopted so it seems like she knows she
was adopted when she found out we don't
entirely know and it could be that like
odin showed up when she was like
five or six because she looks like she's
around maybe seven eight or nine at the
time that she's taken away maybe a
little bit older 10 or 11 or so but it
could be that
that odin and then alternate reality
defeated laffy and then took her
and then adopted her at a time when she
was old enough to understand what was
going on she says she only remembers
little bits of asgard but a lot of that
could be because of the fact that after
hopping through the time stream for so
long that eventually those memories just
kind of fade away and the same capacity
that you can't remember
exactly what it was like playing on the
playground when you were five years old
or when you were 11 years old because as
time has passed
those memories have faded so because of
that i would say that maybe she was
adopted relatively soon but regardless
that she was taken because somewhere
along the line
every single version of loki seemingly
every version of loki
finds a way to break away from the time
stream they find a way to leave their
reality or to make
changes to the reality that would affect
the stability of the multiverse as it's
been established by the tva now that
begs the question
why did they wait so long to get a hold
of tom hiddleston loki because we know
the lifespan of tom hiddleston loki we
know from the time he was introduced
until the time he died we know exactly
how is how his timeline played out
he was introduced in thor and presumably
did some things i mean we're told his
history he fought alongside thor he was
the god of mischief
but nothing he did from the time that he
was introduced until the time he died
indicated he had the ability or even
chose to
to basically leave his timeline or make
changes to the universe
there's nothing that we saw that
indicated that it wasn't until you got
to avengers end game that he had the
tesseract in his hand
and then he escaped that he jumped away
that wasn't supposed to happen
we know exactly how that event was
supposed to play out he was supposed to
be taken by the
by thor back to asgard put in a prison
cell and then stay there until he
ultimately managed to escape during thor
the dark world and then he died
in the events of avengers end game right
at the very beginning of end game or
really at the at the beginning of uh
infinity war rather like we know that he
died then right so we know how his life
played out and so it would make sense
that it wasn't until he got a hold of
the tesseract the tva snatched him up
and said you're not you know
you're supposed to be here one of the
things that moby has told us is that
when it comes to the timeline
everybody has a guaranteed beginning and
a guaranteed end
now it would make sense that if if
sylvie popped up that when she appeared
that in her timeline was the guaranteed
idea
that she was going to somehow alter the
time stream or she possibly even did it
without knowing it but whatever the case
is the tva showed up snatched her up
brought her in there she escaped and had
been on the run ever since i i think i
think that's what's happening man
i think that basically loki's are the
black priests of jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers what minus the
whole
traveling around all of creation and
destroying alternate realities and that
their origin
is basically the same way as the
molecule man's and hickman's avengers
new avengers that their origin is the
exact same across the multiverse every
single origin of loki is the exact same
and that somewhere along the line these
different versions of loki all basically
found a way to escape
loki's don't die because they're a
product of the multiverse they can't be
killed in that way at least not by the
tva
it doesn't seem to be able to play out
that way we know loki can die because
thanos killed him but there's nothing to
indicate that he wouldn't be able to
find a way to come back
or he wouldn't reappear somewhere along
the line we don't really know that's the
case i mean seemingly
the tva getting rid of them and sending
them to a different location who knows
what that idea is about right i mean
loki's literally told if you stay here
you're gonna die by the other versions
of loki by richard e grant so
seemingly they can be killed but i i
don't know the theory is not fully
fleshed out
but it just it occurred to me that this
is a possibility
and you know because i was talking to my
social media guy tony and he's like yeah
man that sounds like something marvel
would do that like they would introduce
just this random guy who gets
disintegrated when loki first shows up
to the tva facility and then bring him
back later and you find out he's
actually a loki and that fleshes out the
whole idea
that they're literally going around and
just capturing loki's he even raised a
good point in saying there's a fan
theory out there that mobius himself is
a loki i don't know if that's really
true or not i don't think there's any
evidence to illustrate that but
regardless of the circumstance let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section man because i feel like
this could be legit
i feel like this could this could be a
real thing that like loki's are
basically
they essentially are manifested by the
by the multiverse by the universe as
it's trying to break away from the
entirety of the tva but here's the thing
here's another thing to understand here
here's another concept to keep in mind
in the beginning of the show miss
minutes talked about the multiversal war
right saying like you know long ago
there was a war in the multiverse that
that you know basically
almost destroyed all of creation and the
timekeepers came along and
saved the day and restructured all of
reality according to a single timeline
let me ask you a question
who's to say that's not doctor strange
two multiverse of madness
we know the tva does not exist in the
existing time stream meaning
there's it's not like they're a thousand
years in the future they exist outside
of time right they're not bound by time
and so because of that
the events of doctor strange multiverse
of madness is just an event that
happened over there
it's not really anything that happened a
thousand years ago or in 500 years
or three minutes ago it's just an event
that happened and so if that's the case
then literally the tva was formed in the
aftermath of doctor strange two
multiverse of madness and if it really
is somebody like kane the conqueror
who's pulling the strings it would make
perfect sense
because if you look at doctor strange
two multiverse of madness you look at
all the chaos and everything that's
going on and then somebody like kang
steps
in in that craziness and that insanity
and then basically seizes control or
tries to operate behind the scenes or
something along those lines it would fit
in perfectly with loki that's exactly
what came the conqueror would do
right that's exactly what king the
conqueror would do in a situation like
that i don't know my theory is not fully
fleshed out but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments it's
just it's something that occurred to me
and i was thinking about that and i was
like oh my god this sounds like
something the marvel cinematic universe
would do it sounds like something marvel
would do
i don't know i don't know if it's true
or not i don't know but i believe
it is something that would do i have no
idea but let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section i'm sorry
i'm so excited people it's just it's
really exciting when i come across
different when i have like an idea like
this
i get i get really i get really excited
right you gotta get really excited
because it is an exciting
time to be a comic book fan
and to be a person who loves comic book
shows it's an exciting time let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching i
will catch you all later
peace